Changing the world isn't always a good thing,
even if it's with a really catchy song.
A new character holds surprising depths in the new
"One Piece" movie – and her first song makes
her plans clearer than you think. Warning:
spoilers ahead for "One Piece Film: Red."
"One Piece Film: Red" is the 15th movie adapted
from a 25-year-old manga series, but its success
shows this franchise is anything but tired.
"Film: Red" broke records in Japanese cinemas,
netting more than 15 billion yen in just over
its first month of availability and becoming
one of the most profitable releases
to ever run in Japanese theaters.
Uniquely for the series, "Film: Red" is something
of a musical. While its characters don't express
themselves in song in traditional musical
theater fashion, the movie revolves around a
new character named Uta who performs songs
that underscore the events of the movie.
In total, "Film: Red" features seven songs
available to fans on a soundtrack EP that
effectively doubles as an album by Ado, the
real-life singer who performs Uta's vocals.
While Uta initially appears to be an
altogether happy and optimistic pop star,
some heartbreaking events in "Film: Red"
eventually reveal her true goal. While
her purpose may be hidden from viewers at first,
looking back on the lyrics to the first song Uta
performs in the movie hints at Uta's true nature.
"Why are you so chummy with Princess Uta?!"
"Yeah, tell us!"
Early on in "One Piece Film: Red," viewers
learn that Uta became a popular singer after
broadcasting recordings of her music
all over the world in an attempt to
ease the lives of those negatively
impacted by the New Age of Piracy.
Partway into the film, however, viewers find
out that Uta's singing traps its listeners
into a dreamworld over which she has full
control. Furthermore, in a dark twist,
she harbors intentions to end her own life,
taking everyone trapped in her dreamworld
along with her. Her widely-broadcast concert and
massive popularity leads to her having influence
over a significant portion of the world's
population, who she wants to help permanently
escape from suffering under piracy. They're
decent intentions – but it's not a good plan.
The first song Uta performs in "Film:
Red" is titled "New Genesis." While the song at
first seems to be about creating better world,
some lyrics betray a darker meaning – like
"Say goodbye to everyone who stands against
us / No one has the power to stop
a change that comes through music."
and
"Say goodbye to
everything that's weighing you down / Transcend
beyond reality to colorful worlds of music."
The lyrics may sound innocuous enough on the
first listen, but with the benefit of hindsight,
Uta's real plan starts to become perfectly clear.
Of course, Uta's motivations are also entirely
understandable. She sees other people suffering,
and intends to use her power to stop it.
When she sings lyrics like "We can choose
the way of our future / Try a brand new path,
if I change the world," she's not necessarily
masking some sort of hidden evil, but simply
indicating that she wants to change the
world, albeit in a misguided manner.
At the film's climax, Luffy naturally stops Uta
and saves the people trapped in her dreamworld.
Which isn't surprising – throughout all
of "One Piece," Luffy also wants to change
the world for the better, but does so by
confronting and defeating evil head-on.
Uta, then, serves as Luffy's foil in "Film: Red,"
sharing an interest in positive change but acting
on the goal in a more antagonistic fashion.
"Film: Red" producer Shinji Shimizu highlighted
Uta's uniqueness in an interview
with Anime News Network. He said,
"In 'One Piece' films of the past,
there's always very strong, bad,
dare I say stereotypical types of enemy figures
that Luffy and his gang would beat up and fight,
but with this movie, that is different."
Considering Uta's appearance as a pop idol
as opposed to a fearsome warrior, he's certainly
right about that. But regardless of her looks,
Uta's intentions to change the
world, regardless of consequences,
are clear – and if you pay attention to the
lyrics, it's all there right from the start.